what's up guys bangbang lunch money time
on a Monday while she's trying to get
rich the rest of us just trying to get
our lunch money right on here with the
beautiful and intelligent plain Amer
Nova also known today as a blue Smurf
fashion are you ready for president or
are dealing like a smurf I'm gonna go
with Smurfs what's going on with the
Gerry stock picker mr. Jerome Powell do
you want to do the noise it's Monday we
print and baby we print did you watch it
I did I wrote about it this morning -
what i watch it what happened well he
said that GDP could shrink more than 30%
but he doesn't see another depression
listen I took away two things from this
so first of all he recorded this last
Wednesday here aired last night I
thought that Jerome Powell in some weird
way was able to walk a line of both
being rational and absolutely insane all
at the same time and what I mean by that
is he was incredibly rational in terms
of hey The Situation's bad the road to
recovery is a really important first
step we have to get on that road before
you can worry about how fast it'll
happen
and we are basically being held hostage
by coronavirus there's a lot of things
the Federal Reserve can do but there's a
lot of things we can't do and it's just
gonna have to be reliant on the virus
being control all of that was very
rational and I was actually very
impressed with the responses he had
where he then took a hard right straight
into a wall at 90 miles an hour and hid
the irrationality world is saying things
like yeah unemployment could peak around
20 25 % or GDP and q2 could drop 20 or
30 percent but we're not gonna have a
Great Depression like environment what
are you specifically talking about here
is he's basically saying the US economy
was really strong which is a fact
pre-pandemic so February and before we
were at a record level of unemployment
GDP was rolling stock market all
time highs all of these signals were
really strong then the pandemic happened
but the economic crisis is not happening
from within it's an external force he
said it's kind of like a natural
disaster caused us right so he's like
his point is basically if we can get the
economy started again and get on the
road to recovery we will overcome this
in the strength of the economy should
come back the question is how fast that
will happen or how long it will take I
generally think that Jerome Powell is a
smart guy I generally think that Jerome
Powell is doing all of the things
necessary to solve the short-term
problems remember the short-term
problems or being addressed with all the
money printing the interest rate
manipulation all the lending facilities
etc it's the long-term problems that are
not being addressed actually being made
worse he specifically said look now is
not the time to worry about that stuff
right did you watch it I said no no what
do you think do you think he should have
done the interview yeah why he's gonna
talk to the people
well they did ask him they didn't ask
him what's the money printer noise sound
if they did that it 60 minutes clip
would have gone viral it would have
ripped through the internet yeah he said
well we do it digitally which is code
for we just edit or bank account which
is very much in contrast a big coin but
yeah that's a whole nother topic so
Jerry Powell what rating do you think I
give him for his performance last night
yeah it was every performance but what
do you think I don't think I mean crew I
mean I've always know he's a smart guy
like he's working on 50 plus million
dollars he's ahead of he's a chairman of
the Federal Reserve he's not an idiot
right but at the same time I think he
got like a beat a solid beat yeah which
is like not bad okay she only says that
because I grater cooking every night and
I never give above 9.0 9.0 is the limit
nothing above a 303 would be generous
Ryanair Ryanair what are they doing
they're cutting up to three thousand
jobs and if you know their CEO he's a
pretty outspoken die
um he slams the idiotic quarantine
periods and he's criticizing the fact
that he is not taking any government
money relief relief but some of his
competitors are yeah look I mean this is
this guy is a savage from the sense of
he's like look I have a business it's
not going so hot right now
I'm gonna take the steps necessary to
make sure that I have a business in the
future and I'm gonna do all the things
that you would expect me as a capitalist
to do I'm gonna cut jobs I'm gonna go
into the capital markets and either debt
or equity etc I'm not gonna take the
government stimulus money my competitors
all are taking that money and they're
still obviously still cutting hours
cutting pay firing people whatever yeah
part of what's so interesting about this
those he went right after the quarantine
and I think that he is starting he
really hit on this narrative that is
gonna become more popular which is hey
previously we didn't have a lot of
information or data we were all very
scared of the virus we went in to
shelter in place that was a good
decision at the time given the
information we had we now have much more
data and now these extensions of the
quarantine or stupid what he's saying
he's saying countries including the UK
have announced plans to introduce to we
quarantine periods for inbound flights
for certain passengers he says that's a
joke he's in favor of using masks and
temperature checks yeah basically he's
saying look we can do this in an
intelligent way doesn't have to be lock
everybody up in shelters right and
quarantine or let everybody out and do
whatever they want so there's things
like washing your hands masks social
distancing whatever what's really
interesting to me I would ask you this
question but you're knew the answer so
let's play a game how many people have
died in the County of Los Angeles that
is attributed to copa90 but that's in a
day no no that's total deaths in LA
County I'm pretty sure yeah look it up
you can google it that's fine I believe
that it is a very very very very low
number like 13 we'll find out well well
go ahead and get the information oh okay
all right fake news fake news it's still
there it's still a very very low number
it's like
low thousands of people and we're the
most populated counties in America and
when people start to see this data right
it starts to come out that hey look
hospitals have only been ten percent on
average in terms of their occupancy and
things like that people will say we
can't go back and change the past but
you can't open up an economy in a safe
and intelligent way and do it quickly
which goes back to drone pawel saying
that is the path to economic recovery
get the economy back on pace in a safe
way
agreed yep give me I feel like we've
beaten this horse to death now can we
move on to a more interesting horse like
soft pink if you beat the horse to death
would you have blood on your blue jacket
no that used that was a really that's an
analogy okay Softbank
soft bang vision fund lost 18 billion in
the last year in operating loss yeah for
the fiscal year ending on March 31st
with almost 10 billion unrelated till we
work in uber what's interesting is soft
Bank is valuing we work at two point
nine billion dollars that's down from 47
billion last year how much money has
soft Bank put into we work oh my god so
much eighteen billion so literally if
you guys have ever seen it they just put
a wheelbarrow of cash into any work and
then just lit it on fire is eighteen
point five right yeah you know how I
knew that I read the internet so you are
the queen of soft egg coverage when you
were at fortune you used to write about
Masayoshi Son and Softbank all the time
what is your evaluation of what is going
on in South England so Massa is known
for taking really big bets he's like I'm
gonna go big or I'm gonna go home this
is he's done both of those twice richest
man in the world twice and also broke
twice this is one of those situations
where they did not see coronavirus
coming as no one did true but also I
wrote an article a long time ago about
soft things really colorful and
ridiculous powerpoints that they present
during their earnings calls so now in
the latest one they have this
illustration of all these unicorns
running and then there's like the valley
of coronavirus and some of them fall and
die and somehow like one of them emerges
is up Pegasus and it's flying
so he's saying basically like we
invested what'd he say he said he
expects about 15 of the vision funds 88
companies to go bankrupt another 15 will
be successful and make up for the
failures and those will be the pegasi do
you believe that Softbank which had a
hundred billion dollar fund do you
believe that they will return capital
lose money or make a profit on the
Softbank vision fund call it right now
on vision fund one what do you think the
financial performance when we look back
you know five to seven years what do you
think I'll say they'll return the
capital so they'll return what they
invested but they won't make a profit
and they won't lose money I actually
disagree I know you did what do you
think I think it's gonna make a profit
know what I think that they're gonna
lose money what I do not believe that LP
is in that funding to get their money
back
Wow you know why sorry Saudi Arabia you
want to know why why because I think
that just on we work alone
right there is fifteen percent of your
funds gone right and they're gonna have
more and more writedowns and so this
idea that the 15 companies in order for
a venture capital fund to work you have
a power-law so i invested ten companies
eight go you know let's say six go out
of business
three do okay and then i've got one
that's an absolute grand slam it makes
up for the six that went out of business
and the three that are okay the
difference though is where they're
investing in the capital life cycle of a
business right so if you invest in we
work at forty seven billion dollars you
really are only expecting like a two to
three X right so the power law gets
thrown off you actually need more
successful exits in the portfolio on a
percentage basis then just having one or
two that paid for everything else
because you need such a big return and
so I think so rumor has it that masa
oshi son bought a bunch of Bitcoin in
2017 well that is a hot take at near the
height and then lost a bunch of money
like I've seen reports that he lost like
over a hundred million dollars and then
he sold it like classic human psychology
if I was Softbank right now the saving
grace is what I think they should do is
they should take the money they should
buy a bunch of Bitcoin and hold on to it
and that is the only way that they can
become
because it's just the math soft right
like it doesn't matter if they invested
in good companies at this point or not
that the market has moved so drastically
that they're caught and they won't be
able to make money well if you want to
laugh go look at their everly well I did
three years ago Wow
so Everly well was one of the first
startups to announce that it was working
on an ad home corporate 19 Diagnostics
kit and now it has been granted proper
what the hell does that mean
bu alien mergency use authorization by
the FDA bang-bang-bang everything well
Julia cheek I have a podcast coming out
with her tomorrow morning
she is a savage she's built a amazing
business it's all about at-home
diagnostic testing so instead of going
into the doctor's office and getting a
test done there you can simply go on
their website you can order everything
from food sensitivity to now kovat 19
at-home testing they are the first and
only company in the United States that
have gotten approval to actually let you
go on a website hit a button and you can
have an a test set to your home and then
you can figure out if you've coded 19
and this is big because right now
there's all sorts of testing challenges
and in order to get tested you have to
leave your home you have to go exposing
yourself to even more covert 19 risk
this way you can get it at home what's
beautiful about it is this model it's
going to become more and more popular
over time right it's like they were
ahead of the curve they had everything
in place and now they're seeing
acceleration the podcast where there's
fascinating just around with all the
changes in diagnostic testing their two
biggest things is always been
transparency around pricing so like a
lot of people go to the doctor's office
and they'll be like hey I got this test
and in the podcast she talks about a
blood test can cost $11 or over a
thousand dollars depending on your zip
code and you don't know what it is when
you get the blood test done right and
then you don't know if it's covered or
not like all these crazy it's like when
I read the doctor and then I'm getting
these emails of like you owe $60 you $15
look for what yeah well it's cuz you're
a smurf in smurf world think hawkeye
different things going on so I'm just
like I'm just hyped we got approval well
she got the approval the business is
awesome I am a very very proud investor
no do you know why I really like truly
aside from the fact that she's a savage
why so when I met him early on and they
had invested in all these companies she
was the only one who really sent like
really elaborate investment notes to the
VCS whereas your other founders were
like yep do it well see ya with zero
detail yeah she's awesome absolutely
fantastic
speaking of another awesome company
SpaceX what's going on there the next
SpaceX launch will be the company's
first with people on board these are the
super fit
astronauts remember they're going
there's two types of flights I like
American Airlines and SpaceX they're
gonna put people in space but they're
not going to Mars they're not going to
the moon they're going to ISS right yes
and they are flying on SpaceX crew
Dragon capsule
it looks like it's out of a movie
straight up like why because it they
have I don't know if anyone's seen if
you haven't google SpaceX astronaut
suits it literally looks like they're
stormtroopers like coming to invade a
country or new world and they are I
think one of the first private companies
I don't think ever but definitely in a
very long time that's gonna put humans
in space and so it's pretty cool would
you go if you were physically fit if you
had all the training and you knew that
it was a mission where you could come
back like going to the International
Space Station oh if I knew I would come
back well not that it was 100%
guaranteed you come back but you had the
base the probability clinic so for
example if you go to Mars you thought
processes whoever we send is not coming
back they're gonna die on Mars
well like International Space Station we
go back and forth I read this really
good book by ha what was his name he was
the twin and then did the study they
were both Austrian
astronauts I can't see that astronauts
can't see it astronauts it in smurf
world they don't have any astronauts
they talk about all the effects on your
body of being in space for a long period
of time it's not that great what
happened do they get like lopsided heads
well like when you come back it's just
are they shorter and blue and they look
like Smurfs all right so this is pretty
cool do we know what the date is what is
it of this year well this is happening
like like super early super sir yeah
okay sorry hey may 27th will be here you
could turn into the lunch money will do
a little livestream of the watch where'd
you go livestream watching the humans
going to space perfect I need to find a
space outfit for this yeah it's fine I
can get you an astronaut outfit it's all
over eBay
what astronaut astronaut astronaut Oh
Astro not just say like this asteroid
not damn I tried together she didn't do
it all right the last dance it was the
last dance of the last dance was the
final two episodes yeah I really wish
that at the end they had kind of given
us an update on Michael Jordan's life or
like on Pippins lifer I just wanted an
update on all the characters oh yeah
what did you think after watching all 10
episodes of the championship run Chicago
Bulls I think you put it really well you
said Michael Jordan's pettiness knows no
bounds yeah I love that he's so petty
but is that a bad thing
I mean no I guess he's got six
championships he's the greatest
basketball player of all time and he was
pettiest imagine imagine being his wife
and him being in her being like we
understand why you're mad and you'll be
like oh I had to make up that argument
in my head to motivate myself I don't
know if he goes that far but he
definitely definitely was using
motivation during basketball games it
was like that guy got MVP he'd come in
for you so he's a his roommate in
college basically gave an interview one
time and was like yeah you should try to
play Michael in board games and chess
and stuff and literally they never
finished the game cuz the second he
started losing he would just throw the
board and like the table and stuff what
yeah she she gets super mad I've been
smoking her in chess the check the crime
scene we literally should put up crime
tape in our apartment because I have
been demolishing her
action on trip who is winning backgammon
backgammon is a game of luck it's not
actually games you literally roll dice
it's a game in chess it's only your mind
I have a better mind in the chessboard I
move the pieces around I steal your King
it's game over you get frustrated and
Gotha so how many times do I steal your
Queen never all the time ever literally
infamous but see this is this is a
classic fallacy you're worried about
taking my queen I have my eyes on the
prize I stay focused I stay focused I
stay focused and I steal your King game
over check on me sometimes when I do
checkmate I put down the piece I jump up
and I do a Michael Jackson spin move
Michael Jordan's pettiness of course he
literally my favorite part is after he
beat Larry Bird and the playoffs he went
up to him he said f you - which was
amazing and then also he would do little
things like Brian Russell of Utah Jazz
came up to him earlier a couple years
before like four or five years before
and he started talking jump to Jordan
when he was retired saying man you quit
why'd you quit you knew I could guard
you why'd you quit and so he came back
and he hit two game winners on I mean
literally just reminding of a bro you
don't mess with me you don't mess with
black Jesus last night we had a
situation because we were watching it
and they had just won something I think
the championship and they were on the
bus and the bus was pulling away and I
freaked out because I forgot there was a
player laughter they wanted after the
bus it was like let him get on after the
1998 championship or the final scenes of
the last dances the bus pulling away
with all the players on it and the fans
are chasing it and a fan had on a
Chicago Bulls Jersey and plena sir said
wait why are they leaving a player why
are they leaving a player I had to
explain that sometimes the fans were
jerseys the games and therefore they
look like players except for they're not
six foot five have a 40 inch vertical
and throw down tomahawk they did it no
they did actually even better that guy
paid to go to the game and then chase
the bus all right here oh yeah I got
wings
look I'm at here kind so long I'm
growing wings what up
okay wait so I have a mullet ah the
lunch money winner lunch money time
lunch money time we should make a song
lunch Monday mornings whoo Jail born
inside what up now actually take it back
his favorite thing we use okay the
winner and you picked a dick joke no oh
wait yeah oh wait I forgot that's what I
was but I picked him because he no
because he he submitted a few jokes but
apparently not was his favorite one and
I you forgot about guys okay do you
understand how ridiculous it is to live
with somebody who is so naive
and is so gullible and literally is
choosing dick jokes as the lunch money
winner this is incredible this will
never be topped ever he's submitted not
one but two or three so I'm glad that
guys getting a hundred dollars I have no
comment okay but just so we know that's
what you picked that's so much money
winner all right guys listen we
appreciate you watching lunch money
today well while she's trying to get
rich the rest of us just trying to get a
lunch money right go leave a comment
tell us what you think we'll do our best
to answer smash the like button hit
subscribe and we'll see you guys
tomorrow I see you Smurfs